monsieur le président ferrand vous avez
la parole pour dix minutes
voilà s'affaireront ballon quitte le
premier à prendre la parole parmi les
représentants des groupes à la fois de
l'assemblée du sénat
d'ailleurs sénateurs et députés vont se
succéder à ce micro du congrès à cette
tribune du congrès onze interventions en
tout que vous allez pouvoir suivre en
direct sur notre antenne richard ferrand
président du cocan marshall à boire au
congrès monsieur le président du sénat
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement chef collègues
parlementaires
c'est le 16 novembre 2015 que
j'assistais pour la première fois à une
réunion du congrès l'histoire commandait
alors que les représentants de la nation
se rassemblent en souvenir de ce jour
je veux rendre hommage à la mémoire de
toutes les victimes du terrorisme et
exprimer nos sentiments solidaire dans
la peine à toutes les familles qui ont
perdu un des leurs mesdames messieurs
emmanuel macron avait annoncé tôt dans
sa campagne qu'il s'exprimerait chaque
année devant le parlement réuni
je salue cette pratique nouvelle qui
permettra au président de la république
de faire partager sa vision et de rendre
compte de son action à la représentation
nationale les points cardinaux posées
par le président de la république
aujourd'hui seront ceux de notre
boussole pour le travail de la 15e
législature de l'assemblée nationale
face aux défis l'heure n'est plus au
statu quo elle n'est plus à
l'immobilisme mais à l'action
nos objectifs sont clairs y compris sur
les évolutions institutionnelles
nécessaires
il consiste à donner corps avec le
gouvernement au contrat passé
entre le président de la république et
nos concitoyens sur des chantiers
essentiels pour l'avenir de notre pays
contrat qui engage toute la majorité
issue des urnes pour remettre la france
en marche pour permettre aux françaises
et aux français d'être à nouveau maître
de leur destin pour permettre à la
nation de retrouver le mouvement
créateur d'une grande histoire et
aujourd'hui est la première étape nous
avons une obligation absolue de réussite
et françaises et les français ne veulent
plus seulement des intentions et encore
moins des dogmes ils veulent des
solutions
des actes et des résultats il s'agit
d'abord de libérer notre pays des
carcans et des blocages qui freinent
l'activité et pénalise la cohésion pour
renouer avec la prospérité le progrès le
mouvement
l'inventivité pour créer plus de justice
plus d'égalité
il nous incombe collectivement de
décrisper des tensions inutiles de
permettre un souffle collectif nouveau
un élan nouveau de données
prioritairement à la jeunesse de
nouvelles espérances
certaines règles nous le savons toutes
et tous sont devenus obsolètes et
doivent être modernisées alléger ou même
aboli cela passe par une action publique
plus efficace plus rapide plus ciblées
il appartiendra au parlement de sanaa
sur et notamment un accent davantage
notre travail sur l'évaluation et le
contrôle des politiques publiques
nous devons également bâtir une france
et une europe qui protège mais qui
protège face au danger réel que
rencontrent nos concitoyens au 21e
siècle et non pas en référence au danger
passé fantasmé ou parfois même
faussement exacerbée chacune et chacun
dans notre pays doit demain trouver les
clés pour s'accomplir
nous devrons donc créer de nouvelles
protections plus adapté plus audacieuse
mais aussi plus agile qui assurent notre
sécurité d'abord et en particulier face
à la menace terroriste
ensuite qui protège chacune et chacun
des aléas de la vie dans un monde en
constante évolution par une formation
améliorer et mieux calibrée par une
transformation de notre système de santé
de notre politique du logement par une
réforme de l'assurance chômage pour en
faire un droit universel pour chacun et
par un investissement massif dans la
transition écologique énergétique pour
un nouveau modèle de croissance
nous n'y parviendrons que par la relance
d'une europe ambitieuse tournée vers
l'avenir qui investit et qui trace des
perspectives partager mais ce n'est pas
tout il nous faut aussi réconcilier
réconcilier les territoires en
garantissant l'égalité républicaine sans
jamais imposer un modèle unique en
réinvestissant dans la france qui se
sont laissés pour compte
en encourageant ainsi les nouveaux
circuits économiques dans la france d
ruralité dans le monde agricole en
amplifiant une ambitieuse politique de
rénovation urbaine pour lutter contre la
pauvreté et le handicap social en
développant des réseaux de transport
pour désenclaver relier rapprocher des
territoires réconcilions aussi les
français avec d'avenir
avec le progrès avec l'espoir d'une vie
meilleure pour les générations suivantes
et aussi avec leurs représentants
politiques mais aussi entre eux et cela
passe le président de la république l'a
évoqué prioritairement par l'éducation
et la culture qui sont le socle même est
la condition de notre cohésion nationale
la transmission des savoirs fondamentaux
de notre culture et de nos valeurs
républicaines au premier rang desquels
on trouve la laïcité doit être remise
clairement au coeur du projet de notre
école et de nos universités
un chantier majeur au coeur de
l'intervention du président de la
république est chez lui du renouveau
démocratique
c'est pourquoi nous devons redonner
confiance dans la vie publique
nous devons également reconstruire un
projet politique pour l'europe l'europe
et le levier de notre influence et de
notre puissance libérée protéger
réconcilier tels sont les points
cardinaux de notre travail parlementaire
à venir
les françaises et les français nous ont
fait confiance
en élisant une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale pour qu'elle tienne ce cap et
apporte les réponses attendues président
du groupe la république en marche
je mesure l'exigence de cette mission
est la responsabilité collective qui est
désormais la nôtre notre groupe présente
un renouvellement visible des visages à
nous toutes et tous de renouveler
ensemble les usages et les pratiques
il nous incombe ainsi de démontrer que
la politique n'est pas affaire de
posture mais un engagement au service de
la nation ancrée dans le quotidien des
françaises et des français est fidèle
aux promesses faites
l'enjeu n'est évidemment pas de changer
les personnes pour conserver les
pratiques
bien au contraire le travail
parlementaire doit être rénové pour être
en phase avec les attentes de notre
peuple
les pistes ouvertes par le président
sont celles que nous devront explorer
d'ores et déjà nos députés seront
entièrement investi tant à l'assemblée
qu'au près des habitants de leurs
circonscriptions avec je le sais ils
l'ont dit la volonté d'un travail
parlementaire plus exigeants et plus
approfondie c'est pourquoi nous portons
nous portons la volonté d'une exigence
de co-construction en faisant preuve
d'ouverture vers les autres d'exigence
bienveillante envers le gouvernement et
de pragmatisme dans toutes nos décisions
chaque fois qu'une idée nous paraîtra
bénéficier à la france nous la
soutiendrons bien volontiers sans en
contrôler l'appellation d'origine
alors mes chers collègues oui évaluons
corrigeons améliorons simplifions et
choisissons de noeux légiférer que sur
l'essentiel car sinon nous allons
devenir des fabricants de normes dont on
sait chaque jour sur le terrain que leur
multiplication freine l'action et
l'inventivité
regardez le réel en face et la première
nécessité pour le changer et regardez le
réel il faut le faire même temps ça
cogne tendre vers l'idéal pour notre
pays et nos concitoyens c'est notre
devoir pour redonner l'énergie de
l'espérance collective et sortir de
cette forme de délectation morose qui a
paralysé notre pays ces dernières années
soyons en sûr ce sont les forces de la
liberté et les biens
une société fraternelle qui nous
libérerons de ses forces d'aliénation
qu'évoquer le président de la république
nous devons ensemble développer une
éthique de la méthode et des résultats
pour que notre efficacité collective
soit reconnue mes chers collègues
j'en termine monsieur le président
prenons la mesure de l'histoire
et si vous le permettez marchons
marchons pour que l'espoir abreuve nos
sillons
monsieur ferrand